[موسيقى]
أشخاص ولدوا بمستوى معين
من الفضول يدفعهم
للاستكشاف لتجاوز عرض مغامرة
السفر الذي نعيشه في
الصحراء الغربية على بعد حوالي 400450 كيلومترًا
من القاهرة هنا حيث يمكنك الخروج من
كل ذلك ، فقط استمتع بالتواجد في  الطبيعة هي
اللجوء ، شكرًا لقدومك ،
لقد بدأنا هذه الأمة 31 كمنصة
للترويج لمصر كوجهة سفر مغامرات
حيث رأينا دائمًا أن مصر
لديها الكثير لتقدمه أكثر من الأهرامات
والرحلات البحرية ومنتجعات البحر الأحمر التي
كانت موجودة قبل 10 سنوات  لم يكن الناس
يعرفون شيئًا عن مغامرات المغامرة ،
وبعد ذلك مع تطور رحلات المغامرة 32 ،
بدأت رحلاتنا تتطور أيضًا ،
اكتشفنا أن الأشخاص عندما يسافرون
معًا يتم تكوين رابطة
معينة لديهم الرغبة في القيام بمزيد من
الأنشطة معًا في
الوقت الحالي نحن في  الحديقة الوطنية الصحراوية
التي تعد واحدة من أعظم المنتزهات الوطنية في مصر ،
اعتاد هذا المكان أن يكون
مثل المحيط القديم على مر السنين
مع الرياح القوية والعواصف الرملية التي
خلقت هذه المنطقة  dscape ، لذلك عندما
تسمع كلمة صحراء ، بدأت أفكر في
الكثبان الرملية بجوار Y الصحاري والصحراء البيضاء المختلفة في
الواقع تشعر وكأنك
لست على الأرض إنه ليس فقط من
المسار المطروق إنه خارج هذا العالم
والغرب المصري يصحرك  يمكنه
القيام بمجموعة متنوعة من الأنشطة مثل
المجيء إلى هنا والتخييم والتزلج
على الرمال فوق الكثبان الرملية والتزلج على الكثبان الرملية باستخدام
أكثر من أربع سيارات
وركوب الدراجات في الجبال ومسارات معينة ، فإن
الشيء المتعلق بسفر المغامرة هو
تجربة شخصية وإلى أي مدى تريد
أن تذهب بعيدًا عن راحتك  حسنًا ،
ما الذي لا يعجبك أفضل
للمغامرة بالسفر ، انظر إلى مكان
وجودنا وستشعر بهذا الشعور كما لو
أنه يجلب لك شيئًا
لا يمكنك العثور عليه على الشاطئ أو في الآثار القديمة
الآن "  لإعادة التعرف على المكان
بطريقة مختلفة ، سنذهب
للتجديف بالكاياك في الصحراء في بحيرة المياه المالحة ،
كم هو رائع
أنه مدهش
[موسيقى]